hello and welcome to this video
ezel dua 97f completed before and this
follows was a pretty awful loss they
were starting from a fantastic position
and then what screwed it up this is a
pretty awful line for black he has to be
very very cautious not to loose
immediately now this is not a good start
I was amazed that decent players still
playing to this and he's a freedom
master so
yeah age 5 is a big threat he couldn't
take on g4 last move because of Queen a
for winning a piece at the end so what
is his move Queen to 7 well I can check
and then play h5 yeah
why are you not losing the bishop there
is some check on what is the thing let's
see okay maybe you can take with the
Queen and play for Bishop c2 that's
possible it's still not a good position
as possible
threatening King due to now tramping the
trapping the bishop okay I can't play
King the two still the night I can go to
if form
there's also F for wet F for
intermediate move let's do that I really
want to win this game the game that had
the first game that I had against them I
was just absolutely terrible not to win
at once it was a similarly bad position
like this one so yeah just takes
everything isn't this Bishop trapped why
isn't it trapped show me so then you
place 93 probably
[Music]
that does work indeed it's a bit tough
to believe but it doesn't work
[Music]
in 93 come on are you serious
what's this night is 3
and believer
it's an it's amazing trickery here look
see to America you have to play like
that if you play such a such a bad setup
in the opening when you are essentially
lost you have to hope for those kind of
things and sometimes they work like here
Bishop before kingly 2093 amazing that's
the caption I'm just not having a just
don't have anything here night see June
it's no check take their time morning
yeah I know
frustrated just frustrated I knew I'm
not a great technical player this guy's
much better in tactics than I am
but still yeah I mean playing this this
way and then surviving it is system all
wrong 93
yeah miracle miracle miracle okay I Roxy
ate him okay I didn't pay any attention
anymore that's really terrible again it
is the second time I've got this kind of
this kind of game against this person
[Music]
white resigns they switch it on and you
scroll back a couple of moves and then
you see like plus four or something edge
I'm just too stupid to do it him
I have four and this is not winning a
coin to the end and don't give me that
now that's impossible
okay so Queen a four Knights is six
Jamie yet this this thing is trapped
basically it's trapped is there really
that really works technically that
you're not losing the full piece there
amazing that's amazing and that isn't
even a good move F for a craziness he
can take their which is unbelievable to
Mia and it's decided in four seconds
like like it's the most natural thing in
the world and all those tactics work and
they work like bye-bye exactly like that
he has to play a five now to have a four
I'm sorry I'm 52 a for it just works by
by one tempo and will be eight and now
this one that wasn't me that my door was
just slamming on its own accord
yeah and come on basically either he has
you keep did he calculate that in four
seconds what and he has to have all that
otherwise this Bishop is trapped it's
crazy
sorry that's crazy okay I can do this
and he still just about saves the bishop
come on now and now we have this tactic
you know and I cannot take on c2 because
of rupee one that's all working by one
tempo and this is easily played in
Tyrell I mean what is that this just in
a genius so what great yet this seems to
be better but here you know I'm not
winning the piece and I wanted to win
the piece like I should that's somehow
but this is all working by one move
check yeah yeah I was completely losing
the threat yeah you don't need to lose
immediately probably but yeah
this is all stuff has a reputation of
being completely unplayable d4 is better
than d4 is better than Queen a form yeah
I know this this guy is the concept of
playing something complete rubbish and
then play like genius that sets
fantastic it really it really is great
that this works I mean he has to somehow
whatever figured out that this does work
like all Bible by one move
[Music]
still stuck ok anyway thanks for
watching